let's get back to hearing from you via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to adam from los
angeles california adam you're on the
air
hey david uh so i actually wanted to ask
about um
daca and the dreamers sure um obviously
it's been a roller coaster for them
um and you know now with a slim majority
in the house and senate
how likely do you think it'll be for not
only people who are
in daca but people who maybe narrowly do
not qualify
um to get some relief i'm confident
that the doc current daca participants
current
participant doesn't seem like the right
word those who currently qualify for
daca status
i think that in relatively short order
they are going to be taken care of now
in terms of expanding daca to include
more people i think there's more of a
question mark around that and it's
really too early for me to have a strong
sense of
of how likely it is that daca will be
expanded
totally yeah because i know even as
recently as 2019
um the the dream act um obviously got
blocked by mitch mcconnell in the senate
yeah um and didn't even be it wasn't
even brought to a vote but i know the
bill itself has always had
bipartisan support so hopefully you know
something can happen there
you know the the the disgusting reality
is
there are despite bipartisan support
there are likely republicans who may
want to stand in the way
merely to deny joe biden an
accomplishment on this and that's really
sad because we're talking about people's
lives being at stake here
oh yeah livelihoods may be better said
no
def i i think it's disgusting and i
guess the hope is that um
you know something can get done about
that you know would they need
um any bipartisan support even to pass
it
you know that's a really interesting
question it's
without really reading more about it i
don't know
how much can be done by simple majority
how much can be done by executive order
and how much would need 60 60 votes and
so
i i don't have an answer on that at this
immediate moment i think it's something
i'm gonna have to read up on absolutely
well thank you so much for your time
david
my pleasure great to great to speak with
you uh we are hearing from folks via
discord
at davidpakman.com
discord